you know what uh jennifer coolidge
recently said that she would love to
have you play her in a biopic are you
game for the part absolutely is it about
jennifer
well i think that she she's just shows
up like i think she's fantastic in
everything that she does so i would be
honored congratulations on causeway and
being here at tiff what was it about
this part that you just had to dive in
and take it on full throttle
there was
just something that
i i had to make it with urgency it was
it was bizarre i mean i i think i loved
the melody of it
um and the pace of the film and there
was something that i connected to with
lindsay and knew that um
we could make it great we could really
turn it into something powerful what did
you tap into to get to there mentally
for to portray a soldier that was you
know reintegrating with society and home
well we were dealing with um you know a
tbi and all of the
and post-traumatic stress all of these
things that i'm i'm not personally
familiar with so we spoke to a lot of
vets and a lot of um
of heroes that that had experienced tbis
in the line of fire and
that helped me glean a little bit of
knowledge about the recovery and
in that process i'm an army brat so in
the future oh wow yeah come on down to
fort campbell kentucky and i'll give you
the grand tour and introduce you to as
well you should have to tap me for some
research jen
i gotta say big congrats on motherhood
how is motherhood treating you so far
wonderful thank you yeah doing most
these days are you looking forward to
screaming this red carpet in the event
and get back to hubs and the babies
see your husband here this evening to
celebrate so you're turning it into a
date night of sorts
in the sense that we'll both be in bed
by nine
lovely finally julia stiles was singing
your praise to us about
you and silver lightning's playbook of
course this november marks the 10th
anniversary of that film what do you
remember about
oh
what do you remember most about taking
part in that film um
god i don't know i mean i remember i
remember the audience's reaction after
when we premiered at tiff and i was so
young i was 21 when i made that movie so
i remember kind of like not getting it
like when we were filming it and i was
just like it's kind of a comedy but this
part's sad
and then seeing
watching it with an audience and then
the audience's reaction it was just so
overwhelming and unexpected
[Music]